welcome to this video playing shark ento
55 from Paraguay okay okay that's not a
very shocked like opening the exchange
variation d for that was played quickly
mm-hmm taking with the night interesting
midnight have 60 our d 4 is quite
uncommon in the first place but yeah
playable no no doubt they'll just
castling okay I can play the C 5 p-6
setup no wasn't sure what to what to do
now the c7 pawn is weak but it's two
bishops let's get out of them out of the
D file there
I don't know if I want to play rook the
age to trade stuff
if I've is not really a threat but I
guess trading some some materials you
should be should be okay yeah that's not
very ambitious but he can play that roof
of course let's take and go here okay
did not expect that at all like c4 and
so on that looks decent decent for black
Queen you hate I'm not sure about that
but it gives me the e-file why not why
not and rookie one I can take queen of a
king of aid check Jeff that's not very
exciting but I have some space on the
queenside at least maybe some ideas
there is there some way to do don't do
something here before I don't know do I
want to play a five let's start with
that and push this point to a three at
least then I know what porn might
possibly promote later
so okay this way he makes sure that I'm
not playing Knight takes e4 at any
moment let's do this six any any way
forward here that's really probably a
hopeless cause let's do this light
coming to five you will never move this
night away they're really not I wonder
if Knight b6 a4 if i take p 3 i'm not
promoting even draw a third Jim that's
probably the way to do it but i wonder i
still wonder if i have any kind of idea
i cannot take on b3 i can shuffle a bit
i mean it's not like he's threatening
anything
sometimes you can try to win and if you
are able to provoke the other side to
play for win but I don't know if I can
do that here it seems kind of
unrealistic and the problem is that i
really have no idea in this position if
I again if I play f5 run over to a five
and then sacrifice even that is not
working
I really have no idea that yeah it's
just hard to close everything
check yeah is never ever going to move
this night away there and now it does
move it away doesn't it doesn't matter
though ha ha ha ok game draw yeah well
they didn't do much for most of this
game but I I really should have tried to
be a little bit more I mean it's this is
this is equal yeah don't don't think I'm
I think I'm better here but maybe I
should go at five or something to at
least from at least keep this going a
little bit but it's difficult sometimes
against the exchange variation if they
really play without any kind of ambition
to generate something night 95 maybe I
played this badly here I am b5 this is
stronger with this idea actually Andrew
piayed yeah maybe check yeah ok I'm
guilty as well yeah with Queenie a time
trading Queens I thought that and maybe
have something on the queenside but
that's not not really materializing here
this is quite quite nothing to be
perfectly honest ok a draw is the draw
as a draw thanks for watching